anytime I'm doing a voice which is often
for me it's based on someone I know no I
tried to get away with it so pretty
woman I was like 23 years old 22 I
played like a cop out on a Hollywood
Boulevard I had done a TV show before
that and told everybody I was gonna be
in it as you would do and then got cut
from the show and I was really
embarrassed and bummed so I didn't tell
anybody that I had gotten this few lines
and pretty woman because I just assumed
I was gonna get cut and then by the time
the movie came out I forgot that I
didn't tell anyone and I got all these
calls from angry relatives going why do
you tell me you were at a movie I'm like
uh-uh
forgot I didn't tell people that was
fine I was booked that that's the movie
that made Julia Roberts I mean I think
everybody in show business already knew
she was gonna be huge who's coming up
that would be mystic pizza but that
movie really made her heat that was
insanely great working with Al Pacino a
hero of mine growing up Michael Mann who
directed um he does a lot of takes a lot
of takes the point where you get a
little cross-eyed and we shot that scene
without where he screams she got a grasp
that scene which he had said normally
like a hundred times because she got a
great ass and then I guess he had been
maybe got driven crazy by how many takes
he had to do and decided to yell it into
my face from a foot away to which I
reacted to by going Jesus like that not
acting just terrified which ended up in
the movie the only ad-lib at all of my
better sit up from the movie with me
don't Jesus well Pacino screamed at me
Moe the bartender on The Simpsons is
based on Al Pacino but young Al Pacino
Dog Day Afternoon Michael Corleone II
Pacino who's a little higher
Serpico Al Pacino and I did that for Moe
the bartender and my audition for The
Simpsons and they said we like that
voice
to be gravely so if you take out but you
know I'd make him gravely you get motor
bartender some since yes probably mo I
just he's been the most developed and
closest to my heart always sort of a
weird version of young Al Pacino made
gravelly no this gets out the next words
you say will be muffled by your own but
police chief Wiggum there's an imitation
of Edward G Robbins and there's an old
old gangster actor $4.99 four days
Wickham yeah right master mm-hmm an
elephant just knocked over your mailbox
okay and it's actually my impression of
Mel blanks impression I've had word G
Robinson Mel Blanc for your kids playing
at home was the original boy somebody's
bunny another Warner Brothers cartoon
characters snake is just kind of Jeff
Spicoli from Fast Times and also a kid I
went to college with it was always
stoned okay kumbhak guy is another
friend of mine from college and of next
door freshman year
Oh loneliness and cheeseburgers are a
dangerous mix get a Barcalounger in his
room he would sit in it and he would
have a list on his little dry erase
board outside his door if he liked you
you are his good list if he did not like
me that week you're on his bad list
maybe you were on my list was the basis
of Martinique is a pretty bad impression
of Ricky Ricardo everybody
so yeah I just thought it would be funny
to talk like this they assign roles in
the Simpsons based on their instincts
for who will do what best and they're
usually right sometimes they're not
right and we will either say oh you know
I think I do Johnny Carson better or or
actually oh I don't do a very good Fred
Flintstone I think Dan does I didn't
know till many
later kids that there was an original
Moe the bartender voice that I replaced
I didn't know that and I was like did
you just did that guy you didn't like
what he did and macaroni was like oh no
he was great I'm like so then one
why did you recast him like oh he was
just a dick he his voice was great but
he was just kind of jerky to everybody
think about how awful it that guy could
have been like on The Simpsons his whole
life lesson the kids it'd be always be
nice friends the TV show friends I
wanted to be Joey and they they said no
as you might be aware of and someone
I've ever asked to go back so you know
what he got to see me again
I got tried again that's how much we
knew friends was gonna be at least
really funny we couldn't have known
there was gonna be that big a hit
everyone I knew was like crazed to get
in that show they rejected me from Joey
but then I was lucky enough to the movie
quiz show which kind of raised my status
and they liked me in that and they gave
me that role of Phoebe's boyfriends
scientist boyfriend The Birdcage
directed by Mike Nichols Mike had seen
me in quiz show he offered me any small
role I wanted which was nice but its
small small role I picked that one which
he thought was crazy he was like why
really that one I was like yeah yeah
yeah
and then he heard me do it at the table
read and he laughed he said okay I can
see why you'd like to do that sure
and then later they ended up expanding
the role it was supposed to be just one
scene David Alan Grier was supposed to
play the main you know Butler character
but they felt that an african-american
in that role might be in poor taste it
was based in a French film so they ended
up deciding to make it Latin and give it
to me and then I worked on a Guatemalan
accent very hard and it ended up just
sounding exactly like my maternal
grandmother as I was wearing I'm like oh
this just this sounds like my grandma
mad about you I played a dog walker who
talk like this he kind of spoke this way
which is sort of based on a kid I grew
up with when that have been a doorman on
my building
when did I become an actor and I'm doing
this voice for years and I run into that
guy he was hey you know I saw you on mad
about you I was like oh really
I was like yeah he said yeah I thought
it was great he didn't realize it was
based on him so I'm glad I didn't say
I'm sorry I didn't mean to appropriate
your entire be Godzilla that movie
became the sort of poster child for what
was wrong with Hollywood excess and
budget and you know marketing style over
substance you remember the billboards
and yeah unfortunately for that movie
the ad campaign was a lot better than
the movie itself it was really
excoriated like it was didn't do well at
the box office people really was one of
those projects people really jumped on
hating much to my chagrin because it was
a big break for me and so that movie
doing well would have been very good for
my career I remember it was like a
five-month shoot it was a long shoot
never roland emmerich the director
saying to me about a week before we're
gonna shoot like so I decided that if
we're gonna be in the rain every
exteriors gonna be in Zoe and the whole
time it's gonna be raining raining
raining and it make the creature look
great because the blurry lines and there
was the early days a CGI so anything
that helped it look visually better was
good and I was like awesome I remember
coming home and telling my girlfriend at
the time about that it was a very
experienced actress who had shot a lot
in the rain
I had never shot in Hollywood rain she
was like oh my god that's terrible I'm
like why she's like you're gonna be sold
you talked about 12 hours a day for five
months every exterior you're gonna be
something like oh how bad can it be
it was really bad Hollywood rain isn't
big drops like having buckets of water
and dumped on your
practically but anyway it's horrible I
got like sick for times being wet is the
work that's like more than anything else
being soaking wet for extended periods
of time that'll that'll make you
question your career choice mystery men
one of my favorites blue Raja master of
silver well I just sag and that it
should be a proper British voice I don't
know why it seemed funny well it was
funny about that
we decided that he's just putting that
on in the movie like when his mom talks
to him is like mom whoo and then you
know that's with his mom and then as the
blue Raja who's his sophistication sort
of James Bond if you will that was again
the early days of CGI there were a lot
of cooks me and Ben Stiller and Bill
Macy and Janeane Garofalo and and Paul
Reubens and and the director was a
first-time director who came from the
commercial world and there was so there
was no real strong daddy which is really
what a director should be he announced
in the middle of shooting it kingka
Usher's name that he was done like I'm
not direct I'm gonna happily go back to
commercials where I make a million
dollars pop and don't do a lot you crazy
people he was done halfway through the
movie but there was a lot of intense
arguments on that like you know Bill
Macy dressed as a Shoveler the Shoveler
and me dressed as the blue Raja throwing
forks at people and I was like like
seriously arguing with each other and we
look absurd
dodgeball a true underdog story at that
point Ben was making these films and
invited me into that yes patches
o'houlihan which is a kind of a
combination between Clark Gable and when
I imagine a young Rip Torn to be and
yeah that was fun I just came in for day
and was silly and left that at the
Museum to battle of the Smithsonian big
ben stiller franchise fourth kalos
impression i play the villain the evil
Pharaoh comes back to life
originally that was going to be sort of
voice similar to what I did as the blue
Raja their little less flowering sort of
more casual and bored British they felt
it was a little boring and so we at the
makeup wardrobe test they threw up a
microphone and I tried out some voices
and as a joke just alter talking his
board of Caral because he was the
original mummy back in the 1930 and they
really liked it Ben and Shawn Levy
really liked him like really guys cuz
this is a little silly like no no no
that's funny
a long game of believe I did a French
accent in that blood yes glute
yeah hippo story everybody that's made
them it yeah that seems to be the
takeaway from that film you know when
you're gonna be naked in a movie it
really motivates you I can see skew bad
but what are you for scuba are you
you're nothing as the French would say
let me know when you're for scuba
Anastacia the fine animated film what
would you like to know about the Bartok
it's based on a cousin of mine I told
you I based these characters on real
people this is my cousin a girl cousin
actually and always stayed in my head is
be good for something and sure enough a
little white bath who knew brat man most
importantly a black man I love it it's
my favorite thing I've ever done fit
most fun I have doing it started as a
voice as most of my characters do it's a
voice that I grew up imitating the
baseball announcer of the 1970s or they
all sounded like these kids go look it
up go on YouTube find a baseball
broadcast from the 70s you're gonna hear
this guy well you know Harry Shearer at
The Simpsons who I work with does the
voice have been Scully on the show a lot
it's brilliant and Harry and I would
talk about over the years how baseball
announcers are hilarious because they
can say whatever they want as long as
they give the count afterwards you know
man oh man I am jacked up on heroin
right now breaking ball misses outside
wanna know so I thought that would be a
funny premise for a sketch which we made
for Funny or Die and then developed it
into a full-blown a series about a very
alcoholic drug-addicted sex addicted
insane baseball announcer thanks GQ for
sitting in listening in looking in as I
blathered on about my career
[Music]